[Applaudissements]
en effet la philosophie c'est une
discipline magnifique je m'intéresse
depuis plusieurs années et c'est même
elle qui m'a conduit à m'intéresser à
l'intelligence artificielle en effet
l'intelligence est une notion hautement
philosophique et là l'intelligence
artificielle pouces plein des grandes
questions de la philosophie occidentale
alors comme on l'a dit avant je suis un
petit peu geek à des heures donc j'ai
regardé ce que ça donnait au niveau de
la technologie
et puis je suis un entrepreneur dans la
vraie vie on va dire donc j'ai regardé
quel impact ça avait sur la société chez
les gens dans les usages et en mixant un
peu ces trois regards jean suivi à une
conclusion c'est que l'intelligence
artificielle est une opportunité
évolutionnaire pour l'espèce humaine
on parle beaucoup des risques mais c'est
une opportunité alors je parle pas ici
d'un transhumanisme technologique dans
lequel il s'agirait de brancher nos
cerveaux à des intelligences
artificielles pour augmenter la
puissance de notre intelligence
ça viendra sûrement mais moins ce dont
je veux parler c'est d'une évolution du
rôle de l'intelligence plus que sa
puissance alors pour expliquer un peu ça
il faut déjà expliqué un peu ce qu'on
entend par intelligence qui est souvent
après rapprocher de la rationalité
comme si la rationalité est un bon
critère de l'intelligence et c'est même
comme ça qu'on mesure le cui la
rationalité était entendue comme une
façon de résoudre un problème de façon
juste cette conception de l'intelligence
comme rationalité elle nous vient tout
droit de l'humanisme des lumières qui a
posé la faculté de raison donc la
faculté d'être rationnel chez l'homme
comme le propre de l'homme comme sa
faculté rennes comme ce qui même le
rapprocherait du divin et donc on
pourrait dire en utilisant des termes
philosophiques que l'humanisme des
lumières a opéré une réduction de
l'homme à un homme rationnel
un nouveau ratio alors il ya quand même
une autre idée dans l'intelligence et
qu'elle est capable d'apprendre et dans
ce paradigme de la rationalité
l'apprentissage sert à optimiser cette
rationalité en accumulant de la
connaissance autour du problème qu'on
veut résoudre en prenant un problème du
coût qui doit être très bien défini très
restreint très contraint ça c'est une
logique et une logique de spécialisation
on va apprendre en faisant converger
notre savoir vers un domaine
un problème moi ça me fait un peu penser
à ça donc à charlie chaplin qui au bout
du millième bull bull ont en effet le
sert de façon plus rapide et plus juste
tout comme quand on était à l'école et
qu'on a appris à faire 6 7 8 fois un
exercice la neuvième fois on le faisait
de façon plus rapide et plus juste alors
ça c'est vrai du secteur on va dire
secondaires et de des ouvriers qui on
connaît un petit peu ce cette image de
l'ouvrier aliéné à sa machine qui fait
le même geste toute la journée mais il
ya des gens qui font aussi ce même geste
intellectuelle toute la journée
par exemple j'ai vu des avocats qui
passait des journées entières à éplucher
des cas de jurisprudence à la recherche
de mots clés et j'ai trouvé ça tout
aussi inhumain tout aussi aliénant que
l'ouvrier qui répètent le même geste
derrière sa machine toute la journée
donc je me range un peu à la vie d'une
rue beauty sienne que je connais qui m'a
dit un jour si vous faites un travail de
machines c'est normal qu'ils soient
remplacés par une machine est en effet
aujourd'hui
l'intelligence artificielle dont on
parle tant remplace un certain nombre
des tâches même hautement intellectuel
de l'être humain et même en termes de
rationalité elle est bien meilleure que
nous c'est un stack et l'excellent on
devrait même on pourrait être plus juste
la plaie rationalité artificiel on
pourrait dire d'une certaine façon que
la machine rationnelle la maquina ratio
va l'homme rationnel l'homo ration est
en théorie de l'évolution on le sait
quand une espèce est battu par une autre
sur son propre domaine
elle a deux choix soit disparaître soit
évolué et je fais plus courts plutôt
confiance à la race humaine pour évoluer
en terme d'intelligence
d'une part parce que ça c'est très
récent ça date de à peu près quatre
siècles l'humanisme des lumières et la
rationalisation du travail qui en a
suivi qui en est une des manifestations
elle est assez récente on va dire de
trois siècles
et puis parce que dans la nature
l'intelligence l'intelligence vivante
elle ne fait pas ça du tout
l'intelligence vivante elle est plongée
dans un environnement qui est nuancée
qui est varié qui est divers qui est
extrêmement complexe et donc elle n'a
pas du tout le loisir de se concentrer
sur un seul problème pour l'optimiser
puisqu'on l'a vu optimiser la résolution
d'un problème en accusant de la
connaissance
sa demande que ce problème soit très
bien défini et très restreint en plus
cet environnement échanges
beaucoup donc elle a des problèmes
multiples qui changent constamment et
elle doit apprendre cette intelligence à
résoudre différents problèmes de façon
suffisante mais non optimales alors dans
cette logique l'apprentissage ne sert
plus à optimiser mais sert en fait à
s'adapter
on n'est plus dans une logique de
spécialisation mais dans une logique de
diversification
on n'est plus dans une logique
d'accumulation de la connaissance mais
dans une logique de flux de
connaissances on actualise constamment
pour être à jour vis-à-vis de
l'environnement et à mon avis c'est même
pour ça qu'on a à capacité d'oublier et
des connaissances qui deviennent
obsolètes
quand on accepte de les faire évoluer au
fil du temps en fonction de notre
environnement
alors il ya une métaphore que j'aime
bien c'est la métaphore des systèmes
ouverts donc un système ouvert en
physique en biologie en chimie c'est un
système qui change constamment influent
avec son environnement pour se maintenir
donc typiquement un corps humain c'est
un système ouvert qui échangent un flux
d'énergie avec son environnement en
mangeant et en tirant de l'énergie par
la nourriture et en leur crachant sous
la forme de dissipation de chaleur et
d'effort et il a besoin de ce flux pour
se maintenir c'est un petit peu comme si
le corps danser un tango avec
l'environnement qui fait que quand
l'environnement change ses pas de danse
se modifie notre corps doit changer ses
pas de danse et se modifier lui aussi et
c'est pour ça qu'on a la capacité
d'évoluer toutes les espèces évoluent au
fil du temps en fonction de leur
environnement
eh ben c'est un peu pareil pour
l'intelligence on pourrait la comparer
un système ouvert qui échangent
constamment un flux d'informations avec
l'environnement et qui doit pour
maintenir ce tango qu'elle danse avec
l'environnement se transforment et
évoluent et quand l'environnement évolué
et là ça demande du coup que
l'intelligence ou en interaction
constante avec l'environnement qu'elles
soient ouvertes finalement qu'on soit
curieux et la curiosité c'est un bien
meilleur critère de l'intelligence que
la rationalité
on le sait aujourd'hui chez les animaux
comme chez les hommes alors cette idée
de
couplage avec l'environnement on
pourrait dire ça impose que quand
l'environnement propose une nouvelle
configuration notre intelligence évolué
propose elle aussi une nouvelle
configuration
une nouvelle interprétation pour cet
environnement et des nouvelles solutions
aux nouveaux problèmes que pose cet
environnement donc tout ça ça fait
beaucoup de nouveautés heureusement on a
une faculté chez l'homme qui permet de
gérer la nouveauté et c'est la
créativité et donc là vous voyez un peu
où je veux en venir
je veux en venir à un humanisme une
conception de l'homme qui n'est plus
fondée sur la rationalité mais qui est
fondée sur la créativité la rationalité
restant très pertinente mais ça devient
un outil au service de la créativité un
outil qu'on est capable d'externaliser
aujourd'hui dans des machines dans des
intelligences artificielles et
aujourd'hui en plus avec l'environnement
qui change très vite dû aux technologies
et à l'environnement social etc
on a d'autant plus besoin d'être créatif
et de nourrir cette capacité à être en
interaction constante avec
l'environnement à être curieux de
l'environnement pour continuer à danser
le tango avec notre environnement qui
accélère ses pas de danse
donc comme on appelait tout à l'heure
l'homme rationnel homo ratio pourquoi ne
pas appeler l'homme créatif homo creatio
et puisque le mot ratio est l émanation
de l'humanisme des lumières
je propose que le mot creatio soit
l'émanation d'un humanisme que j'appelle
ouvert en référence à ses systèmes
ouverts et à ce besoin de curiosité pour
constamment s'adapter constamment être
créatif
bref je propose qu'on désapprouve un peu
l'héritage culturel que nous a laissé
les lumières et qui nous semble si
évident aujourd'hui qu'on laisse
l'intelligence rationalisant tôt
intelligence artificielle qui le gère si
bien et qu'on tourne nos efforts
d'évolution vers la créativité vers
notre capacité à s'adapter constamment
alors tout ça c'est on va dire la partie
un peu théorique un peu philosophique
mais ça a des conséquences concrètes
parce que si je présente ça c'est que je
puisse je suis convaincu que cette
transformation d'humanisme elle a lieu
aujourd'hui dans la société et qu'on
envoie des émanations un peu partout
donc je vous propose un petit exercice
de pensée
cette pensée de la transition du travail
par le prisme de cet humanisme ouvert
alors ça m'intéresse comme problème
parce que la transition du travail c'est
un problème très actuel qui se pose du
fait notamment des intelligences
artificielles qui viennent remplacer des
tâches qui étaient faites avant par des
humains et donc il faut peut-être
inventer des nouveaux métiers pour
c'est humain et inventer des façons de
former ces gens tout d'abord avant de
penser à des nouveaux métiers il faut
penser une nouvelle économie dans
laquelle ces métiers vont vivre alors de
même qu'en lorsqu'on est automatisé le
secteur secondaire ça a permis le
développement du secteur tertiaire
je pense à ce que l'automatisation du
secteur tertiaire invite à créer un
secteur quaternaire dans lequel on
échangerait tout ce qui a trait à la
créativité et au changement l'adaptation
aux flux etc
il ya trois piliers que j'ai identifié
pour sept en tout cas au moins trois
piliers que j'ai identifié pour ce
secteur
le premier c'est la connaissance donc la
connaissance non plus entendu en tant
que accumulation mais entendu en tant
que flux est à mon avis la plus grande
entreprise du 21ème siècle sera une
entreprise dans la formation et dans
l'éducation parce que d'une part la
connaissance la formation ça vaut très
cher ça se vend très cher et d'autre
part quand on est dans une logique de
flux
c'est un super business model le besoin
il est constant il est renouvelé donc à
mon avis là il ya un potentiel
économique exceptionnelle ensuite c'est
la créativité alors la créativité je
vais pas revenir sur le pourquoi j'en ai
assez parlé mais en tout cas c'est un
petit peu le moteur et la connaissance
on pourrait la voir comme le pétrole en
effet on a besoin de connaissances pour
être créatif
est-ce que la créativité ça ne vient pas
de nulle part c'est ni plus ni moins qu'
une reformulation et un maillage de
pleins de connaissances qu'on apporte
dans le monde d'une nouvelle façon et le
troisième pilier
un petit peu plus étonnant c'est je
pense la collaboration et si le premier
était le pétrole le souvenir le moteur
le troisième c'est le booste la nitro
parce qu'en effet on y est on est
beaucoup plus créatif quand on est à
plusieurs c'est démontré en psychologie
aujourd'hui et on le sait en économie de
la connaissance
un des grands principes c'est que les
échanges sont à somme positive si je
possède une connaissance et que je vous
la donne vous l'avez aussi et donc une
connaissance plus une connaissance égale
deux connaissances les changes est à
somme positive on a généré plus de
connaissances en les échangeant donc on
a tout intérêt à collaborer pour être
plus créatif et pour générer plus de
connaissances dire maintenant qu'on a
cette nouvelle philosophie et qu'on a
cette nouvelle économie
on va pouvoir rentrer dans le concret et
essayer d'inventer des nouveaux métiers
alors je vais reprendre mes trois
piliers pour la connaissance là c'est
tout un nouveau champ qui s'ouvre à mon
avis donc c'est tout un nouveau champ
qui est basée sur une reformulation
complète de
ce qu'on appelle aujourd'hui la
formation non plus entendu autour de la
spécialisation mais entendu autour de
cette notion de flux de connaissance et
donc de diversification de la
connaissance non plus entendu en termes
de recherche de compétences mais en
termes de recherche de polyvalence on
n'est plus dans une logique de savoir
faire mais dans une logique de savoir
être finalement on apprend plus des
choses on apprend à apprendre et sa
demande donc de travailler avec des
outils complètement nouveau en termes
pédagogiques sa demande de faire de la
pédagogie autrement ça demande d'être
pédagogue autrement sa demande d'avoir
du contenu pédagogique et des interfaces
pédagogiques différentes et par exemple
les youtuber à mon avis s'inscrivent
totalement dans ce mouvement
pour ce qui est de la créativité un
métier qui commence tout juste à
apparaître c'est le métier d'inspirateur
comme je l'aï dit tout à l'heure pour
être créatif
il faut mettre en mouvement mettre en
action des connaissances qu'on a acquise
et donc pour les mettre en mouvement il
faut qu'elles soient liées à du désir il
faut qu'on ait envie de les mobiliser
ses connaissances et des connaissances
liées à de l'émotion liées à du désir
c'est de l'inspiration et finalement
c'est pas pour rien à mon avis que ted a
autant de succès aujourd'hui c'est qu'il
ya un vrai besoin d'inspiration pour
être créatif et enfin au niveau de la
collaboration un métier que je connais
bien et on dont on vous a déjà un peu
parlé aujourd'hui c'est le métier de
facilitateur donc un facilitateur c'est
quelqu'un qui va permettre à des gens de
background très différent de travailler
ensemble même s'ils n'ont pas le même
langage technique
même s'ils n'ont pas la même culture par
exemple un jeu c'est pas un comptable un
quelqu'un du marketing un ingénieur
codeurs est un anthropologue qui
filtrait autour d'une table pour
travailler sur un projet un peu complexe
qui demande à toutes ces connaissances
de se rejoindre
ça serait pas aisé pour eux de
communiquer et de se mettre d'accord et
bien le facilitateur ça va être son rôle
ça va être l'agent catalyseur de la
transdisciplinarité il va permettre à
tous ces gens là d'être productif et
créatif ensemble donc c'est un métier
pivot pour c'est dans ces nouveaux
métiers qui apparaissent aujourd'hui et
dans cette nouvelle économie et donc
dans ce nouvel humanisme
c'est un métier aujourd'hui dans
l'entreprise on le voit apparaître
vraiment germé de partout et on a même
des entreprises et des théoriciens qui
considère que le métier de manager va se
transformer en le métier de facilitateur
et enfin pour boucler un peu sur la
philosophie et tout en restant assez
concret je pense qu'on est un nouveau
moteur de l'histoire
le moteur de l'histoire de l'humanisme
des lumières c'était le progrès donc un
moteur assez linéaire il ya cette idée
d'accumulation on accumule du savoir et
cette idée d'optimisation on l'a cumul
pour améliorer le cours de l'histoire
éteindre petit à petit vers une
civilisation qu'on espère parfaite dans
un avenir indéfini aujourd'hui en 2007
tous les candidats à la présidentielle
ont utilisé le mot progrès dans leurs
discours en 2012 plus aucun
par contre ils ont tous utiliser un
autre mot qui est le mot innovation et
l'innovation c'est ce nouveau moteur de
l'histoire beaucoup plus chaotique qui
abandonne cette idée d'accumulation
schumpeter expliqué très bien que la
l'innovation c'était une destruction
créatrice
on n'est pas dans la logique de
j'utilise la marche précédente pour
aller sur la suivante
né d'un logique de jeu détruit la marche
précédente et genre construit au même
niveau et donc c'est un peu contenue
dans ce que je viens de dire il ya plus
cette logique d'optimisation
on essaye pas d'aller vers un mieux y a
rien dans le mot innovation qui nous dit
qu'on va vers un mur de même qu' il
pouvait y avoir dans le mot progrès là
on est juste en train d'amener autre
chose on a même une transformation qui
doivent diffuser dans la société est en
effet elles doivent diffuser parce que
l'innovation c'est un phénomène qui est
social et économique et donc pour que
quelque chose se diffuser dans un
environnement il faut que ce soit adapté
à cet environnement et on retrouve cette
idée d'adaptation dans l'innovation
on innove parce que ce qu'ils avaient
avant n'est plus adapté aux conditions
technologiques sociales etc etc on a
besoin d'amener quelque chose de nouveau
de plus adaptée pas quelque chose de
mieux
quelque chose de plus adapté donc je
pense que c'est pas pour rien qu'on a
cette mode cette injonction à
l'innovation depuis quelques années ça
nous vient de cette nouvelle vague ses
nouvelles
à nice mme qui qui est en lame de fond
dans la société
donc je le redis l'intelligence
artificielle est une opportunité
évolutionnaire pour l'espèce humaine
l'opportunité d'évoluer d'un humanisme
de la rationalité l'humanisme des
lumières voir un humanisme fondé sur la
craie avec créativité que j'appelle
l'humanisme ouvert et au passage pour le
meilleur et pour le pire je fais pas de
jugement de valeur
ça nous permet de comprendre pourquoi on
est passé d'une société du progrès à une
société de l'innovation
je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]